hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to what may be the
final episode of fatal frame - at least
I know there were on the final chapter
and I made a choice I went back to save
my you even though my better judgment
would say leave her to the ghostly whoa
Pete what will what do we look at what
are we looking for
hello is there a thing up here wait what
am I looking for just do that to me and
not do anything oh oh ha I don't know
what I'm looking at but I'm looking at
the bottom of a bridge Oh jumping woman
gray caught her mid jump our knees are
so happy for myself okay so I'm actually
running low on Type four oh hey hey what
are you doing I don't have time for you
I gotta get gone to the other place
where my you is because mio is here to
help me oh he's here to collect her
debts I who has been a little bit
selfish in this endeavor I'm pretty sure
that she came this way yep indeed I was
right
wouldn't you know it now am i you don't
follow them they're dead ghosts
yeah I don't think that's what happens
I'm pretty sure the rest of this tale
ends with you both die and the whole
village goes to hell no
a very distinct feeling that what
actually happened here is that the whole
village went through the pit of hell
which is isn't that kind of very Silent
Hill esque
I mean Silent Hill the the entire
village itself or the entire city itself
was just kind of an intermediary between
you know it's purgatory or was it
actually hell I have no idea then again
I have not played Silent Hill teni
serious extent anyway what we got here
no I what no I picked up the thing god
damn it you son of a [ __ ]
I wasn't even near the door why are you
gonna put that right on the edge of
where the door supposed to me I asked
game is just here to piss me off
when we were small we once went to the
river that flows out of the village
that day we made a promise we said we'd
always stay together forever even if we
left the village we would not art yeah
hey we promise to always be together but
my body is weakened I might not be able
to follow you you might leave me behind
just thinking about being alone scares
me as we grow older we'll grow apart we
were born together as one I want to be
one with you again Y then we can be
together forever love sigh how about no
how about a whole lot of no I imagine
I'm gonna have more choices once I
actually get to my you saw what I'm
gonna do and no I'm not gonna try to
find all the alternate endings of this
game I'm only gonna do the ending that I
choose and if you would like to see it
for yourself you're just gonna have to
play the game or find someone else that
played it before I did there were a lot
of people that did that but it's
actually interesting because I've been
trying to summarize my feelings about
the entire game and I don't have a lot
of experience with japanese-style horror
games in general other than the RPG
horror games that I played in the past
but this one has been a really
interesting experience for me because
for one the pacing is very very slow and
I mean that's understandable in horror
game and I can't appreciate a lot of
things that I played in the past that
had very very slow pacing but that does
not mean that that slow pacing is always
enjoyable because one thing that was a
problem with this particular game are
not necessarily a problem but it was the
location that is set in the village is
very small so obviously when you have a
very small village you need to actually
loop
found cover a lot of ground to do things
over and over again that's it you keep
things interesting but that's not always
enough because it does take a lot of
time in between things and I know there
hey what are you doing don't even think
about it
you're not even registering on my thing
hello I faced one of you before there
you oh you made me waste my goddamn
thing I'll be back
since it's gonna take one okay we got
him okay so as I was saying before that
the pacing in this game is dictated by
the village itself in the layout of the
map and the repetition of what it can do
but it's also gated and this may be a
technical limitation but it's gated by
the doors that you have to go through
and the the constant opening of doors
and the constant cycling through
different same set pieces in a
repetitious way such that you keep
things interesting keep moving forward
however I went in a circle why did I do
that um I actually don't know
specifically where I'm supposed to go I
imagine that I'm supposed to find my way
underground such that I would be able to
get to the saram oh no I know where I'm
supposed to go I mean I'm supposed to
see the kusabi I'm supposed to go to the
kusabi and fight it because people have
been saying that the only way you can
beat the kusabi is if you have type-0
film and I have type-0 film so what I'm
gonna do is I'm gonna take this type-0
film and I'm gonna shove it up here but
his butt or butt is but for his how does
that keep happening I don't really need
that in my life okay so I'm gonna keep
that way that door over there yeah so I
mean then again I'm not an expert at
making horror game so anything that I
say take with a grain of salt but I've
played enough of them such that I have a
good idea of what good horror is and I'm
not saying this bad or I'm not saying
this bad in any way please don't
misconstrue what I'm saying and saying
that this game is bad or I had a bad
time with it I had a lot of fun with
this game especially in the beginning
but it did drag on in the middle of it
like it felt like I was doing things not
for the sake of doing them but for the
sake of merely getting from point A to
point B and there's a lot of things that
I saw in this game whoa whoa wait whoa
who's that big guy big guy oh that ain't
big guy who is you who is you get out of
here no one likes you alright so anyway
like I said I'm not saying this bad in
any way but it did drag on quite a bit
to the point where I was actually less
inclined to play the game oh thank you
for turning around again and then there
are the bugs that just annoy me with the
controls and I mean that might be my own
personal thing with it and I have
grievances here and there Garden woman
great why didn't I see you before
congratulations on attending the garden
while you died and but I mean with any
game that I play I like to give my full
idea because I spend so much time with
it that I get it I I form an opinion
evade why didn't I get this before if
I'm in the final chapters it's not gonna
be the final episode allows you to avoid
damage when caught by spear by pressing
the shutter button it says a right
moment to set a flash off and stomach
here okay that sounds good but I rather
blasting back to hell much quicker
because I can avoid the damage not
really anyway yeah yeah uh what was I
saying I said a lot of things I think I
kind of looped around a little bit but
what I'm saying about this game is
because this might be the final episode
I definitely want to summarize my
thoughts on it just because I've been
spending so much time with him
especially when I played games like
alien isolation and evil win within
because the evil within was a fun game
but not a good horror game because it
was not about horror thanks for walking
into the wall there me aw thank you for
not hitting the same point and this game
is good to the point where it's got a
very intricate story and it's got a lot
of things going for it it's got a lot of
interesting set pieces the only
complaint that I have is the pacing of
it and pacing is good for horror for a
lot of reasons it neat allows people to
build up a sense of dread when they you
know otherwise wouldn't have it but
pacing also works against it because you
can easily lose someone's attention and
I played this in piecemeal and even
playing it in piecemeal over a long
period of time I still kind of got away
from the main point of the game because
it just took me so long to play it okay
so I actually I need to consult the map
because I can't quite remember exactly I
need to go if I recall correctly there
was a way to go over
maybe I needed to go the other way I Pro
oh that's right I need to go through
this long part here because I need to go
into this area and then back through
there be ok because that's the only way
that I have not been so I'm just
operating on the assumption that it's
gonna be over there so that leads ok let
leads the integral ah that's right it's
not the underground cellar but it's the
area around it in the connecting
corridor which I'm here and if I go
through that room there then that's
gonna lead to where I need to go but I
could have just as easily gone the other
way because I'm a big dumb dummy and I
was talking about something else so
probably wasn't relevant to what I was
doing right now but I imagine there's
been a lot of downtime in between me
getting to mio or my you know my you
that's what I was saying I keep getting
to this point where I get strike by what
I'm doing and then I don't remember what
I was doing then I get lost over and
over again yeah I could have very easily
just gone through the other door there
so excuse me it's just a lot of me time
to talk so what was I saying I can't
even remember I've no one here to check
me I just have you guys here which I
love you for being here
you guys are awesome for sticking with
me for this long I know there's been a
long game it's taken a lot of patience
to get where we needed to go but I found
the right place
hey I'm Mayu I'm following a butterfly
because I have no attention span and I
can't stop looking at crimson
butterflies hello sir excuse me while I
walk through your body not in a weird
way right so I mean the interesting
story dynamic is here and again I did
not explore everything that there was to
explore and I probably missed some
secrets here and there butterfly hooray
for me I mean it's obviously getting a
clue as well stop doing that stop
changing the camera like that I do have
problems with the cameras in the
controls that's a totally different
story though but I'd like to judge this
you don't know me or you don't know my
you that's my sister not yours saw a if
that is sigh oh no if I stay here some
day Y will come back for me can I become
a butterfly without her if I could I'd
always be near the village waiting
waiting at the place we made our promise
so didn't you kill the rest of the
villagers just so you could wait for you
Hey she'll come I know she will
I have no idea no idea at all so where
was a connecting corridor through here
and it's consult the map real quick so
I'm in the altar room I imagine if I go
I need to go up the stairs oh no I need
to get there now I need to go up the
stairs I'm pretty sure okay
oh no that goes down the stairs I need
to go up the stairs there we go
okay so like I said controls aside and
pacing aside the story itself is
actually quite interesting because I've
managed to pretty much get a good idea
of exactly what's going on here and I I
don't imagine I'm gonna be surprised
when it gets why did that I didn't even
touch anything it just went round ah
controls is ID okay
so just from a purely objective
standpoint though one of my other big
biggest grievances about this game is I
did not find it all that scary
um compared to a lot of games that I
played in the past because Japanese
horror differs greatly from American
horror or what you would call I don't
know Triple A title extreme Oh horror I
don't know what you would call it but
the horror that I've played in the past
considerably compared to and needs you
the Dark Descent and whatnot is very
different and it's a vault just like
comedy has evolved over time so has
horror and what it means for something
to be scary so when I play this game I
come
it's easy
you you your bones are your arms what
are you talking about there look about
this way I forget exactly which way I
needed to go but I don't feel like I'm
in the right area cuz I think this leads
god dammit just turn you dingus
you son of a [ __ ] you're just making me
not like the controls yeah I know your
arms your arms I get it I hear it now so
now that I'm over here yeah like I said
horror has changed over time in horror
the threshold for for me personally has
changed a lot because I not scared by
some of the things that definitely
scared me when I first started doing
horror games on YouTube and that comes
with the territory you become numb to a
lot of things that you get constant
exposure for so I personally enjoy
having a lot of new experiences come at
me and I enjoy having a lot of new
things you know to see and to hear and I
definitely like there we go gotcha white
kimono Thank You ru yah my the
embodiment of a yeah a so I definitely
like when new things come at me and a
lot of things this game were new but
also they felt very old and dated and
again that's not oh you're sorry I'll
get back to whatever saying oh no I'll
get back to it right now okay
type 61 film good I need that because
I've been running out of 14 I've been
using 14 through this whole damn game
hello is it time to jump headfirst into
the middle hell who's here for the pit
of hell jump headfirst party alright you
me oh that guy okay
so who is that I haven't been able to
exactly tell him less that well that's
right that was the guy that's the owner
of the camera isn't it
Wow they just threw him right in why yep
you got company here who the hell are
you
you head priest oh hey how's it going
there goody goody gumdrops oh so am i
fighting this guy whoa hey how you doing
so how do I fight you there's gonna be a
long an epic battle Aidan
well do I have more guys no just him
okay
better get the gumdrops where'd he go
[ __ ] all righty then where to go
Oh
where is he oh hey whoa hey whoa Jesus
ah won't sheets how'd you get there
animals had you uh-huh didn't exactly
know what I'm supposed to do there let
me actually change out to a better film
type so that I can do this I'll get to
all my game where did I get 87 pieces of
type 14 all right I guess I'll stick
with all right I'll get so stick with
type 14 nah this guy seems special I'm
gonna do 61 for him all right and also I
need to upgrade my camera because I
haven't done that a long time ah da da
da da da da da no no can't add any more
spirit over there so I guess I'll just I
can't anymore where am I supposed to add
spirit orbs have no idea well he move
already moved to ready for you perv you
may or may not be it's like his his old
areas hey come here attack me give me a
fatal frame I want to get a triple combo
on your ass Hey look at that
nope oh one another
Oh oh yeah triple combo oh yes please
thank you that's sixty one film do
anything for you
feels good don't it real good real good
all right which way to go oh hey how's
it goin there buddy boo
oh no you disappeared oh no I'm so sad
not really I'm just gonna spin in a
circle until you decide that you
actually want to play with me or maybe
you're like oh you're like a boo what is
that ectoplasmic goo that's not fair
you're not able to do ranged attacks no
one's been able to do that before
there's a bunch of debauchery you
sons-of-bitches if I could just stop
like I understand that this is probably
pretty close to a final boss what that
was that I understand this is pretty
close to a final boss battle but this
doesn't make any sense it's totally
illogical for the combat to like follow
this rhythm I mean of course I'm trying
to exorcise the ghosts but I am a little
girl who seems dainty and very sensitive
and does not seem capable of combating
these ghosts despite the fact that I do
have a camera equipment but it's it's
just such a hefty juxtaposition between
the two subjects like what crazy Oh God
do I have to kill these [ __ ] just
yes please oh come on there we go you
son of a [ __ ]
fatal framed you to hell and back holy
[ __ ]
I still got hit by one of those ranged
[ __ ] attacks goddamn okay because you
didn't want to be thrown into a pit of
hell something is on the ground where
the spirit used to be masters key
butterfly design carved into the key to
crystal isn't lying next to the key
chrysocolla okay so I'm gonna listen to
this and I'm gonna talk about what just
happened
because like I'm trying to be
level-headed about everything and I want
to be very objective about what I do
know you must understand such as awesome
who are allowed to you must live what I
say about the
and why is that exactly maybe psy isn't
the one that actually did bad maybe I is
actually the bad egg here
but either way okay so I have a lot of
grievances with the combat in this game
but I will talk about it later I will
shell of my opinion such that we can get
through the story and it won't be
spoiled by it because I do have a lot of
criticisms to take so let's find out
what is going on here ah my you that
seems to be very contrary to what you've
been saying well I've come too far now
okay so mio wants me to leave psy wants
me to stay
sorry about the audio clipping this is a
part of the and why did everyone die
that is an excellent question
oh we're finally gonna see the pit of
hell and we're gonna get to the bottom
of this quite literally in fact this is
very direct oh the right side I didn't
know because I couldn't see because I
don't have my flashlight for some reason
why was that why was that a shot why why
did the camera decide that that why is
this is this important this is important
to remember because this is a great some
where am I gonna be running back out of
here at some point in the future
probably okay either way we're almost
there I got a good feeling my end of
game senses are tingling oh what's this
another diary
oh no it's fluorite okay one more radio
to listen to alright which one this one
no no thanks dad rather not no no no no
no no no no no I know don't know doesn't
matter how many times you say it I'm
still not gonna do it I'm very in the
not killing of oh now I have my
flashlight oh now I deemed it necessary
to pull out my flashlight me Oh decide
flashlight powers activate now not when
it was dark for here it's actually pride
when upright but at least it has candles
I don't know who's maintaining the camp
what is that the big red dildo from
Slenderman oh who do we got with the PO
hey what you oh yeah he's one of the
runner types I gotta get all the way
whoa hey whoa eh whoa Abel
yeah big freaky freaky what gotcha I
probably I'll be right back oh come on
you son of a [ __ ] y'all can talk jet
you're such a [ __ ] haven't saved it
forever if you kill me now I'm gonna be
so angry so unbelievably angry my rage
shall be uncontained among the heavens
I'm just gonna run faster cuz screw you
not like I need to level up anymore
[ __ ]
I really don't know if I'm supposed to
be able to run away from these bastards
but I don't feel like fighting them just
because they're a-holes and everything
in this game seems to be out to kill me
I can't even see where I'm going even
with this they're gonna is there another
one in front of me why now
no get your grubby hands off of me you
ghosty goo I don't care what you have to
say I have enough herbs to last me for
the rest of my life I'm gonna take em
all now cuz I need her skin through this
no god damn it you son of a [ __ ] just
let me go I know that I'm supposed to
kill you guys I understand but it's not
my job it's not in my job description
I've got enough herbs I can handle the
pain okay goodbye goodbye goodbye
goodbye I'm gonna run now I'm gonna run
run so far away where am I going I can't
even see where I'm going I hope I'm
going the right direction because if I'm
not then I'm just gonna be have to climb
back all the way out of here again okay
it seems good the camera decide to
actually follow me now and it's moving
I guess the game programmers couldn't be
bothered to make a camera that was
actually yeah cool
I got a glowy that's a great camera
angle thank you cameraman no no no no no
no no what is that on the ground do I
need that I probably need that
oh you're such a son of a [ __ ] you know
what
1:09 target 1 how about target 1
targeting one is actually really cool
yes god damn it I'm running away I'm
running away so [ __ ] out hate you so
much I hate you so much I hate you so
much
ohh type 90 film that's really good I
hate you so much I hate you hate you
hate you I hate you I really hate you
I'll imagine how much I hate you no did
your grubby no I said no no we all know
no means no where we're going I can't
see a goddamn thing
what what the what in them night what
what okay
oh okay I don't think I was supposed to
leave that man he goes by me but oh okay
I've got a lot of thoughts to say at the
end of this video I will admit that
right now I've got a lot of thoughts to
say about this game I don't know if
you're me oh maybe I no thanks I'm okay
I'm just here for my you yeah I'm here
for my own then I take my you're gonna
be waiting a little bit longer they're
late hmm how about no how did you give
me my you know little conflicting their
eternal ritual ray glad I got that
picture there another picture to be had
ears something else here I'd rather do
neither why do I have to choose okay let
me go to the left over here nope that's
a negatory so can I go to the front or
is this all just kind of blocked off
here I mean this is where the ritual
takes place but this is not where the
pit of hell is because once I get a bit
of Hell I'm pretty sure I'm gonna know
when I see it and I'm pretty sure that
me I use gonna be there do okay here we
go what do we got
that doesn't sound good
here we go
oh hey how's it going why are you
running away
one went horribly wrong I wonder it's
amazing you couldn't do the ceremony
with just one
well I imagine that was the entire
village getting pulled into the pit of
hell my blank no hello can't play now
am I supposed to play or not how am I
supposed to look at that well there we
go
oh that is not good oh you're the COO
sob oh why am i why am i do they do okay
am I supposed to use this now because I
have not saved in a long time I do not
know why it has not given me a chance to
save because I actually don't have and
we have one stone mirror which means
that I could revive if I die because
when that thing touches you die very
hard I don't know if I have five shots
at this I don't know how many I'm gonna
need if I may just need one or maybe if
I just run away that's a big wave oh no
me no me do next
don't be do be do what do you do what
you gotta do that looks bad whatever
you're doing don't do that don't know
that I can't even oh oh oh oh god damn
it damn it [ __ ] a duck oh I just wasted
a shot I saw whoa that is weird
okay that's it okay alrighty then cool
the camera I love that
that's so good if there's gonna be a
it's gonna be a hard shot to make
touch me can't let touch me
give me something here oh yeah I gotcha
yeah oh no I'm not gonna have enough oh
no
Pam let me not fat you dingus oh no that
weights at a shot you son of a [ __ ] oh
damn it damn it
I bet five would have been enough I bet
five would have been just enough but
[ __ ] a duck in the buck in the muck
matiloc oh that did work
oh oh oh that did work it only worked a
little bit but it worked okay so that's
good right
hello my friend are you doing
now oh god don't kill me don't touch me
you're weird and goopy and you thought I
got it I went for the triangle shot but
it's actually hard to time that [ __ ]
when I have to move my finger off of the
reticle so want to make sure that I'm
lined up properly ah
BAM gotcha big dab llege how did you
heal back up did you wheel back up how
did you heal back up what's going on
here I don't much care for this where
you're a big scary goofy not quite
getting the UH the fail frame there but
I only saw it once so I don't even know
how many times I would be able to see it
I'm glad that type 90 is doing some do
it say I don't know if this is the same
one as
might be might be but I'm not sure I bet
it'd kill me in one shot if it touched
me we're yet oh love that camera that's
not nauseating at all
now why was that one a fatal frame but
the other one was not gotcha okay did it
dunh dunh dunh zou donesies you're done
you're done you're done I don't know
what that means but you're done did I
done zit okay then
can I move now no the cameras it's gonna
be weird okay did I do it oh I'm going
back what down the tunnel towards the
actual place is my you down there was my
you blocked off I bet I could have run
away but I didn't because I'm breakeven
I'm Brava Brava revival what's this
final letter y you came for me after all
please hurry I'm right below you I know
you might not make it in time but I'll
wait for you until the very end that's
very nice but was that the final letter
written before she was thrown into the
pit apparently she was hung by the neck
before she was thrown into the pit which
is great comfort absolutely phenomenal
so happy that this loving family is here
together at last
my you my you please tell me here my you
don't be sorry
I don't like sigh I like my you well I
don't like my you cuz you're creepy as
hell but whatever my not you I'm a dark
dark please
shall we begin
no what do they mean resent me what am I
do let me do oh no was I not supposed to
do that
oh we were born together but we have to
live and die separately I knew this I
knew my you will be together we will
he can't be together forever oh can you
stop that no no I didn't I didn't
volunteer for this now you know No
wait
is that the end that's not what I chose
you
okay all right okay all right I need to
get out of the credits because goddamn
freaking piece it what's this what is
this what is this what is that wait
didn't we always promise each other
together forever okay all right I have
some opinions I have some goddamn
opinions I have some opinions about this
I'm an opinion minion right now because
goddamnit
I've got some serious Frick frakkin
opinions about what's going on here
because there's some bull [ __ ] going on
here and I'm just a little too sassy to
be able to handle this right now okay so
first of all I know there are multiple
endings in this game and I don't know if
I made the wrong choice down to the
bottom whereas I took a picture of her
or I should have went up and talked to
her I don't know if it would have made a
difference
frankly the save that I had was so far
back that I don't even know if it would
have mattered like oh my goodness like
okay I have some serious serious
opinions about this game one oh god
where I said give me sick okay to
summarize what I have to say about the
game I will elicit into three separate
points the environment the gameplay in
the combat or know the environment the
story in the combat with the environment
it's what I said before the town is very
small so there's a lot a lot of stuff
going on there and you need to loop
through a bunch of stuff over and over
again
which leads to a lot of wandering now
I'm not one for backtracking
I hate backtracking I don't like going
back tracking I don't like being lost in
the game especially when I shot up I'm
trying to talk here no no no no no no no
no okay
so so especially when it comes to me
wanting to get through a game and trying
my best to focus on what's important and
what I need to do when in reality this
game had a lot of elements that made you
look around and force you to look around
and do stuff and that's totally fine
that's totally fine it's my own opinion
that I don't like that because I like a
more straightforward Avenue about it
especially considering that the
alternate endings were not that apparent
to the choices that I was making I mean
obviously there was some points were
obviously academic choice I could have
gone out left my you behind or I could
have stayed back and done something
about it maybe that was the only outcome
that I could've had I did not feel like
I had a lot of control over the story
though because in my opinion I only had
one way that could have gone and I only
had one way I've could have done but at
the end there I don't know if I made the
wrong choice or not and the whole time
that I was playing through this game it
was just really really interesting to
see because I wanted to know more about
the story which leads me into the story
part of the game I wanted to know more
because the story actually didn't
intrigue me and one thing about Japanese
war is that it does tell stories very
very not specifically it does not give
you a lot of information about the
stories but see not right away because
it wants you to know what the game is
about in the accordance with the game as
it's being played and that's fine like I
said in the previous point that is fine
for the gameplay that it was for the
story that's fine that is the story that
it was but unfortunately it led me
astray because I didn't know what my
accents were doing I wasn't getting
feedback from my actions whether they
were good or not it did not make sense
to me that Mia was so unaffected by
everything I mean from the player's
perspective of being able to see my you
being affected is interesting but mio
was not all that affected by herself so
as a character it led me to believe that
there was not a specific enough reason
besides sisterly love to continue
through the house and explore the deeper
elements of the story I only wanted my
sister rescued and even in the beginning
the game I didn't even want my sister to
be there because my sister was creeping
me out there for the motivation of the
main character was lost upon me because
I did not know exactly what I was doing
there was disconnect there but there
might not have been a disconnect for
other people that were more associated
into discovering the story stab at God
Amos stop stop stop stop stop I get it
yeah yeah okay so with the story it was
actually really interesting and really
good to see how this town was you know
catapulted into darkness but I don't
know anything about the ritual I don't
know why there was a hole in the ground
that led to a pit of hell I don't know
what the deeper elements of the
sacrifice was all about or why it needed
to be done or
like there's a lot of elements in here
that could have been better explained
through more motivation to make me want
to find it because I may be playing this
for you but I do play this for my own
enjoyment I wouldn't play games if I
didn't enjoy them and that's not to say
that I didn't enjoy this game I did at
times however the story did not lead me
to want to pursue it I had questions and
I wanted them answered but I couldn't
find an avenue for those questions to be
answered in the game now the game itself
I have very big grievances about the
gameplay aspects of this game because
video games as you know should be fun
now that does not mean that this one was
not fun because the exploration factor
and the mystery behind it tying in with
the story and the environment worked it
did work it worked fine the camera was a
great idea to be able to exercise and
see things that were not their apparent
to the hidden I now me going into this
and me thinking of fatal frame and
knowing what it I thought that the
ghosts wouldn't have been seen unless I
had the camera up now the camera itself
eventually became a chore and that's a
problem because the combat was the main
aspect of the game thing that kept
driving things forward because
oftentimes I only knew that I was going
the right place when enemies showed up
therefore I had to clear out the enemies
put half the time I didn't have to clear
out the enemies I could have just run
away and there was no consequence for
just running away so it led to this
point where fighting became an
unnecessary element it became a
grievance or it became a chore like I
said before it became a chore and that's
a problem because when you give people a
chore in a game it's not fun chores are
not fun chores are a chore it is a
problem that the combat element which is
such an integral part of this game
became this burden upon my enjoyment of
the game and the controls also but I
will I did I was pressing buttons god
babe will you stop that I'm trying to do
a talk so with the elements of the
gameplay that also irked me in terms of
the controls and the camera like those
are just probably technical limitations
limitations because this game didn't
come out on the PlayStation 2 and the
PlayStation 2 was not the most advanced
console that existed at the time because
people were just starting to get into 3d
and they didn't know so I can forgive
that I can forgive the
but the pacing my capital thing was the
pacing of the game like not just the
pacing of the story or anything the
story I can understand because it's slow
and builds but the pacing of the game
that causes you to go into these combat
aspects that take so long to get through
and they're so finicky and they're so
not obvious and when you get hit it is
so inconveniencing and it's not heart
pounding it became nothing after a while
in this game while good I will say that
it's good technically it is good and the
story is good but the gameplay was just
not up to par of what I wanted it to do
and it wasn't even a fall to my own
because in the beginning of the game I
had no idea what is doing but and it
didn't really teach me that quickly how
to get in the world supposed to go but I
did learn I learned eventually because
I'm relatively good at games and I can
figure out what I need to do but the
unfortunate factor is the game wanted me
to do something and didn't tell me why
um it did explain a lot but it and what
I mean by that I'm not saying that it
didn't explain anything or didn't have
tutorials anything when I say that it
didn't explain to me why it didn't
explain what the benefit of shooting
those demon shooting the ghosts were why
that was a necessary aspect not only to
stop them from killing me but why it was
integral to the story of the entire
village and why these people were ghosts
in the first place and I feel like that
was a big big disconnect because I never
felt like I belong and what's
interesting is because you're a little
girl placed in a haunted village and
that's totally fine because you have a
twin and I get it they were drawn to
this area and they were drawn to the
sacrifice because this whole town was
haunted with this particular problem I
was doing things
god damn it it just doesn't like me okay
so but what's tying in to the gameplay
and I feel like I've been rambling a bit
and I lost my thought because I keep
getting distracted by that but my main
grievance was the pacing of it because
the pacing of what was going on in the
game
totally drew me out of the experience
and I will readily admit that I played
it in big chunks at a time and I will
readily admit that if I had sat down all
at once
without acting worried about recording
it that might have been a better
experience for me but I don't think it
would have changed my opinion of it all
that much the controls irritated me the
combat bored me and the game didn't have
the scares that I was hoping more people
told me about this game and I read
reviews about saying he was one of the
scariest games ever played and by the
second episode I was not scared like in
the beginning of a new whose mystery and
interesting up by the second episode I
was ready to be scared and I was left
wanting because this is a horror game
people say it's one of the best horror
games of all time but I think that
exists in the time that it existed
because this game before there were more
evolutions in horror that came about and
I'm not saying that
jump-scare horror is better that's not
what I'm saying I'm saying there are
better more immersive ways to create a
sense of dread than what this game tried
to do in the technical limitations that
it had now all that being said I'm not
saying this is a bad game or I had a bad
time but people often want to hear my
opinion about this sort of stuff because
you sit with me for this long through
this long playthrough and it was a long
blade through don't get me wrong for me
especially because you guys didn't see
everything that I went through because I
cut a lot of stuff out but for me to go
through all of this and have this
experience thrust upon me and to go in
here wanting to be immersed into it I
did not feel like it lived up to the
bias that I have and I do have bias I
will admit I have bias in what I want
out of horror game and I have bias out
of what I want in a story because I love
immersive stories and I love good
gameplay and I love big scares and I
love amazing interesting intricate
things I did not get that out of my
experience playing this game that does
not mean that it's a bad game that does
not mean that I didn't have fun a lot of
the time that did not mean that I did
not enjoy myself that means that my
opinion of the game from a technical
critical aspect of it is just that the
game left me wanting therefore I give
this game a Marga bar out of nothing
because I don't have a reviewing system
and this is wholly
point.but so you guys aren't left in the
lurch if I am offending anyone about
this game whose big fan of this game I
apologize this is my honest true opinion
about this game after playing it through
to one ending and I know there's
multiple endings but to one ending that
I found from my own choices it left me
what what that doesn't mean a bad thing
I'm not trying to step on anyone's toes
here this is just my personal experience
from the game so either way that's all I
have to say about it I've rambled for a
long time about my opinions of the game
but I feel it's fitting because I played
it for so long
first of all I want to thank you guys
everyone who was stuck with this
playthrough from the beginning and
tolerated my inability to complete
certain tasks and my frustration with
the game at odds and ends because I was
very frustrated at certain points and it
did hurt me now that I could continue on
about that but I will not but I just
wanted to say thank you everybody who
has joined me thus far I know that these
long series are sometimes a haul but I'm
glad that you stuck with me for so long
I'm glad that you stuck with me till the
very end of this game and if you want to
see the other endings try to find them
I'm sure there's plenty of videos on
youtubes that will showcase every ending
of Fatal Frame 2 if I find one I'll put
in the description below but thank you
again everybody so much for watching
thank you everybody for joining me thank
you everybody who suggests these games
for doing long Let's Plays I know I'm
very particular about them and I don't
do them all that often mostly because if
I'm gonna invest as much time I want to
make sure that I have a great time with
it because that means you guys are gonna
have great great time watching but there
was a lot of jokes and a lot of fan art
and a lot of cool stuff that came out of
this so I am happy that I play this
don't think I'm not don't think I didn't
have fun don't think I regret playing
this game because I do not I just had
some opinions and I wanted the voice so
thank you everybody so much for watching
check out the other long plays in all
the amnesia custom stories that I played
on the description below and thanks
again everybody for being here
and as always I will see you
in the next don't call Holdings in
Oh